so the Marvel aspect of my channel is
kind of in a weird situation and the
reason why I say that is we had secret
Empire and then we have Marvel legacy
number one the one shot that will
basically set the stage for the future
of Marvel's publishing on we don't know
exactly what's gonna come next but what
we do know is that in the interim
between the time that these stories
start getting published and right now we
have Marvel generations and Marvel
generations are just one shots they seem
to be filler stories but they may also
tie into things later on down the line
but Marvel publishes their comics
monthly which means that we have a lot
of time until a lot of these stories
begin to wrap up and so until we do I've
just been grabbing like random stories
different things that I thought would be
kind of fun to cover and just sort of
throwing them in there you know throwing
them out there and seeing how you guys
respond but this is a story where
Wolverine breaks the clause I'm sorry
that Sabretooth breaks the clause of
Wolverine and it's really cool because
this is actually one of the more
interesting stories about Sabretooth
really this all goes back to the first
fight between Wolverine and Sabretooth
himself and the reason why is because at
Marvel you have two versions of the
Sabretooth character you have the modern
version that we see unlike the Weapon X
stories different things like that who's
a lot more toned down then you have
classic Sabretooth who is just like a
mindless beast in like a force of nature
he is savage in the extreme it's it's
crazy I can't think of very many
characters out there right now they
could actually stand against classic
Sabretooth I mean within reason like I
mean Incredible Hulk easily but when it
comes to like the Wolverine family like
x-23 or Dakin or something like that
even old man Logan would probably get
rekt by classic classic Sabretooth I
mean he was just an absolute nightmare
but the first time that Wolverine and
Sabretooth ever fought one another
Wolverine was actually spared he was
saved by the common of the combined
efforts of a woman named Viper and a guy
named Seraph now staff ended up dying in
the entire conflict but Viper went on to
basically have this sort of life debt
that was owed by Wolverine in the sense
that Wolverine said because you spared
my life I owe you you know I owe you my
life I owe you a debt you know now the
idea is that that debt will be called
upon somewhere along the line
we don't know when we don't know where
and we don't know what the favour will
be asked that will be asked a viper what
we do now is that when that request is
made Logan is honorbound to fill it and
that's why things are kind of crazy
because this also ties into the element
of a place called Mad Report now Matt
rapport is one of these places and
Marvel Comics that for the most part the
heroes give it a pretty wide berth I
mean it's really just allowed to be its
own thing now it is an actual territory
in southeast China and it does have its
own Chancellor ruling body different
things like that but it's really one of
these places where it's like as long as
the existing status that is to say the
government's ability to control the
island or at least to rule the island as
long as it's as long as everybody does
what they're supposed to do as long as
the status quo is on it's not upset that
people can do whatever they want to it's
basically you look away I look away and
so mad rapport is essentially just a
giant haven for criminals anybody who's
anybody in the criminal sphere knows
about Mad Report now with regards to
Wolverine the reason why this is
important is because he basically became
this kind of mercenary for hire within
major port proper but he built up a
reputation for himself when Wolverine
comes for you your days are numbered and
that's just the way it is a lot of
people contracted him but a lot of
people also have their hands at Matt
rapport the hand has their hands of Matt
rapport no pun intended
Hydra is involved in Matt report almost
everybody there mystique operates out of
a high out of Matt report a lot of
people are based out of that place even
shield does not go into Matt rapport
because if they do then it's basically
hey you come here whatever happens to
you happens to you and the world's gonna
turn a blind eye
a lot of shield agents have gone missing
in Madhupur so it's one of those crazy
situations but with this whole life debt
of Wolverine what we end up finding out
is the sitting Chancellor of magic war
has basically been ousted now I do not
remember the circumstances as to why I
believe that was covered in Marvel
presents issues 1 through 10 but maybe
that focus focus explicitly on Wolverine
and its actions and magic or proper I
can't then we're off top my head but
regardless of why it is there is no
ruling figure in Matt report the idea
here is that Viper is actually working
to become the head of Matt Report now
those of you guys who have read about
our character intermittently you may
have seen her in different
makes different things like that this is
how all that comes to fruition VIPRE is
one of these characters who is very much
involved in the criminal underworld as
Madame Hydra for example she's played a
lot of significant roles but her ruler I
guess her position as ruling magic or is
probably the most significant that she's
played because the person who rules
magic or basically gets it kind of like
everything that goes on you know it's
basically one of these things up hey you
put money in our pockets
we'll make sure nobody comes looking for
you and so because of that it is very
much a scenario where if a person can
take the ruling of majeure poor then
ultimately they're gonna pin it you know
they're gonna benefit by it it's gonna
be one of these really cool scenarios
and so again it is it's one of these
things where we end up finding out that
what Viper had done is that because of
the fact that you couldn't just knock on
the doorstep of the of the Xavier
Institute because she's a villain
because she's wanted in virtually every
country that does not have an
extradition treaty guard that does have
an extradition treaty
what is up happening is she actually
brainwashes a litany of the various
women in Marvel Comics that have been
associated with full of rain now these
include characters like Danny moon star
these include rogue Kitty Pryde
Jubilee the whole nine yards if they are
in any former fashion associated with
Wolverine then they're brainwashed for
the purpose of bringing him to MADD
report now of course this leads into the
actual marriage of Viper and and
Wolverine and this leads into the
arrival of Sabretooth because what
happens is that in the middle of this
marriage once this whole ceremony takes
place
Sabretooth just pops up now here's
something that I want you guys to keep
in mind a lot of the questions that I've
seen and I was actually asking on
Twitter about this you know about how
people like Sabretooth different things
like that one of the things that people
seem to believe is that Sabretooth never
had adamantium that's actually not true
when Sabretooth underwent the same
Weapon X slash weapons Plus project that
gave Wolverine his adamantium Sabretooth
did not originally get it he did not
originally receive adamantium he just
had a healing factor sometime between
the point when he first faced Wolverine
and this story he received adamantium
laced claws and adamantium bones now I
do not believe there is a comic book
explanation for how he got that and if
there is I haven't been able to find it
so somebody please chime in down in the
comments you know and let me know if
there is an actual
answer to that so I can pin that comment
and everybody can know where to find it
but the idea is that with him showing up
here he's more dangerous than he's ever
been because what were in having had
adamantium as well as a healing factor
no matter what damage saber-toothed ever
did to him in the end he would always
end up overcoming the the damage
Sabretooth did he would always end up
healing and then with his adamantium he
would just tear Sabretooth to shreds
absent their first fight with this
scenario wolve rain does not have
adamantium now this goes all the way
back to fatal attractions and that's one
of the cool things about this fatal
attractions was a story we'll cover this
you don't once we get you know further
into a little more x-men stuff assuming
that you guys you know care about this
at all but um fatal attractions was a
story where Marvel was actually trying
to rework the character of magneto there
was a time for about ten years or so
when cared when magneto was a good guy
and a bad guy it was really sort of an
interesting scenario he was one of the
first and most notable and even the most
dangerous enemies of the x-men
eventually he went to lead the x-men and
then reformed himself when x-men vol 2
issue number one came out in 1992 what
Marvel wanted to do was basically send
magneto back to being a bad guy and the
best way to make him look like a bad guy
was to strip strip Wolverine of his
adamantium now one of the other
misconceptions is that when Wolverine
lost his adamantium he immediately went
into a feral State again that's actually
not true what ended up happening is that
Wolverine functioned like his normal
self he went on as a member of the x-men
albeit with bone claws instead of
adamantium it was not until the son of
cable came along and actually tried to
reaiiy guess try to rebound Wolverine
with adamantium and then failed after
that apocalypse was the one who
successfully rebounded adamantium to
over in skeleton using the adamantium of
Sabretooth so it was really kind of a
cool scenario this really interesting
journey with with Wolverine proper but
the fact that he's popped up here the
fact that he has adamantium is a huge
deal because those healing factors
always been there that's one of the
reasons why it is that Sabretooth and
Wolverine always fought so severely but
in this circumstance the tables are
turned
you know try as he might Wolverine can
inflict damage but it's only bone claws
it's only skin-deep going against you
know an adamantium skeleton
basically turns Wolverine into the
weaker guy here it seems like there's
absolutely no way for him to end up
pulling this off
but notice how severe and how intense
this battle is this is one of the
reasons why people look at the feud
between Sabretooth and Wolverine as
being one of the greatest feuds in the
history of comics because these
characters have fought time and time and
time again and they have had some rudl
fights I mean we're talking about just
like cleaving flesh we're talking about
you know just mutilating each other in
the extreme because they fight to kill
and that's the crazy thing about this
because when he became fair Wolverine he
took off into the woods and he was
intense and he was extreme and it was
amazing it was such a cool read but
ultimately in the middle of this
conflict where Wolverine tries to face
off against Sabretooth basically tries
to attack him after Sabretooth plays
possum Sabretooth ends up using his
adamantium claws to snap the bones of
Wolverine to basically destroy his bone
claws now this is huge because what this
does is it basically sets the stage for
things to start moving in the direction
of Wolverine getting his adamantium back
because that's one of the things that
Marvel did when it came to these 1990s
stories in a lot of ways you know it
really built on the Chris Claremont era
of storytelling that they began the
process of focusing on one character and
they would tell this massive story about
this character that would span some 10
years in terms of building them up
showing all their moral compasses
different things like that nowadays you
don't really get writing like that
anymore
nowadays a character's development you
know lasts six issues and that's really
about it then they move on to the next
guy and so it seems like gone are the
days where you get this decade-long
character build the the last time I
would say anything like that really
happened was with the character of
Cyclops where Marvel began the process
of turning Cyclops into a bad guy but
recently it's all really just been
events you know has been the Avengers
versus the x-men Red Skull getting the
brain of Charles Xavier during access is
really all just these major conflicts
and different things like that so
character building has sort of begun to
go away now in truth Kitty prides
ability to phase is just as good as it
ever was right I mean she hasn't like
lost her phasing power
what this does is it actually highlights
one of the big weaknesses of Kitty Pryde
with Wolverine being thrown down the
side of a mountain presumably you know
basically being left for dead what this
does is it leaves us with the
possibility that Kitty Pryde may very
well be killed by by Sabretooth which
again is kind of cool because we're not
cool that she's gonna be killed but it's
kind of cool because what this does is
it leads into the next story which
actually deals directly with the
aftermath and it deals with Sabretooth
Kitty Pryde and Wolverine actually
having to work together but with that
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comics explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you